today for our daily cancellation i'm
going to be canceling preemptively all
the false narratives current and future
um over the latest incident of a suspect
dying while police attempt to restrain
him during an arrest
this is lionel mor morris he died on
february 4th at a grocery store
as police tried to place him under
arrest uh the media
is running with the story the usual
suspects are
chiming in another george floyd they're
saying the washington post headline
is clearly meant to give a certain
impression their headline
if you can talk you can breathe arkansas
cops tell man who later dies in police
custody
okay but all you need to do is read the
washington post article the actual
article not just the headlines speaking
of actually reading articles
to see the truth so let's uh
let's let's do that now let's let's look
at this is like the second paragraph of
the article it says
morris had run from officers on february
4th and then placed one officer in a
chokehold and tried to pull out a knife
according to police
after the supermarket had reported him
for removing a drone from its packaging
i.e he was trying to steal it um but as
an officer had his knee on this
39-year-old's
back inside harp's food store morris
handcuffed and lying face down
repeatedly offered a succinct and
familiar plea
i can't breathe there's body cam footage
and surveillance footage that has been
released and you can see it online
prosecutors cleared the officers of any
wrongdoing in the case and that's why
it's um
in the news now and that's why the
footage uh
the footage was released the footage
shows why
there was no there there are no charges
in this case the body cam video is 45
minutes long i'm not going to play the
whole thing of course
but but here's a here's how the arrest
began at least we'll play this and
you'll see just the beginning of you can
go on youtube to see the rest but
here's how the the arrest started
okay now put your hands on your back
okay
oh
now you can't see a lot of the details
there but you can tell he's running
obviously
fighting the officer ends up on his back
and we're told morris tried to pull a
knife
put an officer in a chokehold um
also here's here's uh
there's there's other information about
this story that's important this also is
from the post but it's buried deeper
down in the article it says
uh the medical examiner concluded that
morris died of methamphetamine
intoxication with a combination of
exertion struggle
restraint and conducted uh electrical
weapon deployment
uh according to a letter from
prosecuting attorney carol cruz to
explain his death in custody
tapeley pointed to toxicology reports
finding that morris had substances
including methamphetamine morphine
amphetamine opioids opiates and
cannabinoids in his system
okay so a whole bunch of drugs to review
here
morris died because he was trying to
steal something
cops were called they tried to arrest
him because theft is illegal fyi
he ran assaulted officers tried to use a
deadly weapon
and all of that commotion eventually
killed him due in large part to the
cocktail of illegal drugs that he had
put into his body
who is to blame here is it the cops who
tried to arrest a man who committed a
crime and then defended themselves
against his violent attack
or is it the man who took a bunch of
drugs tried to steal something
then attacked the officers who came to
arrest him who should we blame
it it's a tough call isn't it actually
no it's not it's not a tough call at all
this this is pretty straightforward and
amid all this talk about
accountability holding police
accountable how about some very
basic accountability for people like
lionel morris
why in all of these cases that part of
it
is always left out what could the cops
have done differently
okay what could lionel morris have done
differently
i can think of dozens of things he could
have done differently
um certainly several big ones like
don't steal if you do steal and the cops
come
okay they have every right to arrest you
you are trying to commit a crime
we live in a civilized society we have
laws if you break them you get arrested
so don't run if you do try to make a run
for it which seems like a really bad
idea because uh you're you're you know
first of all the woman that you're with
is is is
is not running so they've got her
they're gonna find you you're on
surveillance footage you're not gonna
you're not gonna get away
so running makes no sense at all there's
no reason to do it
uh but so don't do that even if you do
do that don't then assault the police
officer when they finally catch up to
you
um and even if you do all of those
things
don't take a bunch of potentially lethal
drugs ahead of time that could
uh you know result in your death i mean
that's that's a list of what four or
five
things that lionel morris could have
done differently and if he had made a
different choice
on any one of those things okay just
just if you
take any one of those points if you had
made a different choice
he'd be alive today and it's it's not a
high bar
either right like don't take a bunch of
drugs try to steal something and then
assault the officers who come to arrest
you
that is not a high bar to get over
it's not like we're expecting something
unreasonable of lionel morris in this
case
he made a whole series of really really
bad choices
and then he died it's very sad
it's like you know it's it's always sad
when someone dies it's always sad
especially
when someone chooses to throw their own
life away for no reason
you know any death is sad but a death
because because you wanted to buy
yourself a
a a few minutes of not being in custody
after you tried to steal a drone from a
grocery store it's like
you're gonna throw your life away over
that it's it's
it's a really sad thing but it's not
a moral outrage uh there's no injustice
here so we we know what
lionel morris could have done
differently very obvious
if you want to start picking apart the
police officers in monday morning
quarterbacking it
uh what what could they have done
differently
let's go through the chain of events on
the part of the officers
they get a call that someone's trying to
steal at a store
they respond to the call we all agree
they should do that right
they're not going to ignore it they show
up to the scene
they investigate the situation okay we
all agree they should do that right
they're going to go up to lionel morris
and the woman that he's with they're
going to ask some questions
uh they find that he that he's removed
the drone from the packaging and left it
you know
on a shelf and has put the drone
somewhere pretty good evidence that he's
trying to steal it you don't do that
if you're planning to pay for it um so
now they know
or it seems very clear that he's that he
was trying to commit a crime
uh so they're going to arrest him is is
that a problem i mean
he was trying to commit a crime again we
do live in a civilized society with laws
i know the left would prefer if we
didn't but we do
and it's their job to enforce them so
they try to arrest them
so far they've done nothing wrong okay
now let's compare
the chain of events we've got you know
parallel actions and choices of the
officers
and lionel morris it's parallel until
they intersect
these parallel choices so far the
officers have done nothing wrong
lionel morris already has made a series
of really bad choices
taking a bunch of drugs trying to steal
something
and now there's the intersection they
try to make the arrest
he runs what do they do here do you
expect them to say oh never mind oh he's
he's running guys forget it forget it
forget it let's go
of course they're going to chase him
they have to he's they're trying to
arrest me right away because
the only other option there is to say
well uh
if you get arrested and you run then
you're you're home free
we might as well not have police at that
point so they tried to chase them down
uh can't blame him for that once they
get him
now he's someone who's resisting you
know this is this is a big
this is a man this is a you know a a
younger
you know this is not like a young child
that they're trying to apprehend here
this is a grown man that they're trying
to operate
he obviously is resisting so they have
to use force to bring him down
now he's putting them in chokeholds he's
trying to grab for a weapon
he is now a lethal threat to them and so
they don't pull out a gun and shoot him
they try to use a taser they use
less lethal means um
and and finally they get him down and
they're just they're holding him on the
ground
while they try to cuff him
amid all that chaos we've already
established that leading up to
the chaos the officers did everything
right i mean there's nothing what else
could they have done
while lionel morris was doing everything
wrong but even amid all the case what
else do you want them to do they they're
trying to
it's it's a difficult thing if you've
never tried to do it i've never done it
but
i i i'll put it this way i'll take the
police word for it that
when you're trying to cuff a grown man
who doesn't want to be cuffed that's a
difficult thing it's not it's not it's
not easily done
and it requires some force that seems
logical to me i could i'll buy that i
could believe that
and so yes they've gotten down the
ground they've got a they're not on his
neck
they've got a knee on the back how else
are they going to affect the arrest what
else do you want them to do
and then he dies because largely
he was he was on a cocktail of drugs if
he wasn't on those drugs he'd be alive
um so it just seems pretty obvious to me
who is
who's responsible here and
maybe at a certain point we could start
just holding people accountable not just
police officers
other people too accountable for their
own actions a really basic bar
that we could say to people you know you
really got to get over that bar
um that society expects that of you
i think that should be our our message
as well so that false narrative is
canceled
a lot of cancellations today been been
good a lot of fun
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content